oh my god the last 10 minutes I was
telling you a story and I was saying
something and and it did not record ah
cooking it's an exercise if you guys
know you use your muscles anyway so
that's a whole story I'm trying to
follow Shaun's guidelines
[Music]
hello everyone this is Nina today I'm
gonna make lentil breakfast actually
make the lentil breakfast video before
the reason why I'm making it again
because last night when I went to
tedious but chata night DJ Doug was
there he was telling me how he likes my
egg tart
quiche thing the snack or breakfast and
he said he really liked it he was a huge
and he loved he lost a lot of weight now
he's trying to maintain that he runs he
workout he wants to build up his muscle
and he was telling me that he needs to
eat more protein and he needs a healthy
like meal healthy breakfast Sasa maybe I
will make this lentil breakfast so he
can get an idea how to make it and he
can always modify it so I'm gonna make
some lentil breakfast but I'm gonna
modify it a little bit more from what I
had made before and also I eat lentils
every morning Evan eat lentils every
morning sometimes I mix I mix some
chicken in there and make some sausage
it depends on what I have in my fridge
it doesn't have to be the same every day
because I don't like to eat the same
thing every day so I like to have some
different flavor mix it up first thing
you only is Lantos you don't have to
soak it every night you can cook coke in
half an hour but you want to wash it
through later because there are some
skins in here this is 4 cups of Lantos
I usually just shrink it three times and
for the water level I just
just let it cover by less than inch and
then let it boil okay so we're gonna let
it boil for half an hour I will add some
onions and I cut up caret-- carrots and
the dice so today I'm gonna add some
this is turkey sausage and this is
ground turkey I will stir fried them and
then wait for the the lentil souk be
ready and then I will mix them together
the reason why I've started to add like
meats in mylanta because my trainer
Shawn every Monday Wednesday Friday we
work out at TDS studio and then one day
outside Shawn I need to lose some weight
and I've been trying but I guess I'm not
doing a good job to lose some weight so
he gave me this booklet basically
telling me how much protein I should eat
a meal and how much vegetable I should
contain consume every meal and how much
carbs I need a day he told me to skip
face 1 because I've done it before with
him so face 1 basically will tell you
protein for men you will need 2 palms 50
to 60 grand of protein female you need
1.5 forty to forty-five grand of protein
these are based on premier each meal he
did this booklet for his 30 days
challenge for his clients whoever joined
the the challenge but I asked him for it
because I want to make sure I eat enough
protein enough carbs vegetable to lose
weight to gain muscles basically and
workout too I'm actually doing the phase
2 so I'm doing phase 2 so for phase 2 he
added the carbs for curbs each meal for
women for men you need 2 cups handful of
carbs 1 cup is when you don't work out 2
cups when you work out and for female
will 1 cup of carbs or 1/2 cup of cars
when you don't work out I want cups of
tow a 16 grand protein if I ask some
sausage or as some ground beef or ground
turkey ground chicken whatever you meet
you at it so I'll make sure I will eat
like 30 to 40 grand of protein a day
meal and try to eat more protein the
morning so I don't I don't have to eat
that many a night one cup of lentils
equivalent to 40 grand of protein so if
I eat one cup of lentils in the morning
which is which means I'm done with my
protein I'm done with my carbs I don't
need to eat anything more anyway so
that's a whole story I'm trying to
follow Shaun's guidelines to consume the
right amount of protein and vegetable
and my carbs to a muscle lose weight
okay so we still have 23 minutes left
I'm gonna wait for the until the last 10
minutes and I'm gonna stir fried them
and I'll mix with my lentils oh my god
the last 10 minutes I was telling you a
story and I was saying something and and
it did not record ah so what I did was I
asked salt in some water into the the
lentils turn the heat to medium and I
was having that I don't really measure
how much ingredient I put in for those
who cooks out there you know when when
you cook you don't really measure you
just feel right now I'm gonna I'm gonna
stir the onions carrots and the meat and
then we will add it with the Lantos once
it's cook so this is already heat up i
heated up earlier when i did not record
so just caramelize the onion
it's a little brown right now I'm gonna
add ground turkey I'm gonna add the the
carrots last because Evan liked his
vegetable crunch crunchy crunch the
ground turkey is 250 grams so that's
about 50 granite protein I will add some
salt so that it's it's not very bland
so the turkey is actually all cooked I'm
gonna add the sausage Kevin loved eating
lentil with his sausage I'm gonna turn
this dough up ready for the lentils it's
ready the lentils it's cooked - let me
just try let me just try one mmm it's
soft so which means it's good you can
mix with tomato sauce or a diced tomato
can I got this from John Vince they have
like they sell bulky stuff but they have
the whole tomatoes and their Italian ho
tomato so I'm gonna add this into my
lentils because it's whole tomatoes I
have to crush the tomatoes it's cooking
it and exercise if you guys know you use
your muscles ok anyways so it's done so
the lentils is all cook you can see with
the tomato tomato sauce in here thank
you some you could still see tomato the
whole crushed Tomatoes I'm gonna add
some oregano besos this is a basis we're
gonna add the oregano here and then mix
well it looks a lot of the condiment
that's not a lot because it's such a big
pot I'm supposed to stir-fry this the
carrots but you know I'm just gonna dump
it to the lentils and let a shimmer for
another 5 minutes
so in low simmer shimmer simmers I think
that's how you say I can never say this
word my friend always correcting me but
I can't always can never get it right so
let it simmer for 5 minutes and we will
turn it off and mix mix the meat
together what I normally do I actually
measure my food but get to the point I
know how much food that heaven and I
need every day every meal so I don't
really measure anymore but for this time
I'm gonna measure see how I do it
he needs two cups of lentils in the
morning because tomorrow we're gonna
work out and after a five o'clock so he
will need two cups this is two cups so
that's two cups over here wait I don't
think this bowl will fit all the food I
will see so two cups nope yes I'm right
so this boat does does not fit I get in
I need to get a bigger bowl so I'm gonna
transfer into this paw this boat that's
two cups so that's what he needs and
then usually for meat I usually give him
a bit more watching I usually have my
meat wrap into individual individual
wrap he usually have like 60 grand
Emilio you should wrap 30 grands because
ie 30 grand of protein but this time I
didn't really I didn't really do that
but it's it's about half this is a bit
more so half we have 50 grand of Turkey
and 10 grand of a turkey sausage so
that's 60 30 so that's Evans breakfast
and I'm gonna give another put a little
bit more sauce turkey sausage because he
eats more and I love him I want to I
want him to enjoy more
so that's Turkey and you mix well this
one has two cups of carbs because the
salento is Kart carbs also in contain 32
because one cup polenta is 16 grand a
protein uh so he has two cups or at 32
grand of protein plus the the 30 grand a
bit more 35 gram of protein so he has 67
grand of protein so that's what he needs
in each meal this is how it looks like
so this is my my usual or our usual
breakfast lentil with different kind of
meats if you're vegetarian you can
always substitute with with tofu at one
point I was like I actually really don't
want to eat meat so eat a lot of beans
that yellow I need a lot of tofu but now
I'm gonna slowly get back to it
sometimes I will substitute my protein
with chia seeds hemp seeds because these
they have protein in there so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video please let me
know how you what do you think if you
liked it or not and if you guys try this
recipe and also let me know I'll see you
soon this is my first youtube video so I
just got home from TDS I'm super hungry
right now I'm not sure
unless you're starving I'm gonna make
some smoothies because I want something
to snack on so that I don't eat junky
stuff meat carrots apple my seniors or
needs try to teach me safe and yes I'm
trying to learn learn crinkle crinkle
Ilse it hurt
[Music]